do you enjoy
honestly being on the set of the flash
and and playing these characters and
working with grant and tom and all these
other people do you have an actual good
time is it a time in your life that
you're like i'm really enjoying this i'm
enjoying going to work i like the
character i'm playing i like what i'm
doing i like being on the show is is
that how you feel
yeah
ted is mostly particularly
but then i was mostly just working with
grant and i knew
with him playing the son who was the
only one to believe that his father was
innocent and me being in prison it would
carve out a very special
relationship for us in the middle of an
action adventure
right at the amusement park you know the
lights go down the music hushes we walk
into the phone booth we pick up the
phones we can't do our business
we're sitting there all we can do is
memorize the words look at each other
make a connection and tell the truth you
know and those were
wonderful and i enjoyed it while i was
doing it i appreciated it pretty soon
after we did it grant was very funny
because i saw him at the upfronts in new
york and he had seen the pilot and i had
and he was like man have you seen the
pilot did you see our scene you know the
big scene with the hand on the glass and
depending on the father-son moment
and i said no
as it is how is it he said man i was
sitting there going you can't cry you
can't cry on your own scene it's so
uncomfortable to cry at your own scene
so grant wanted to cry after watching
did you did you when you watched it
did you did you cry when you watched it
i don't remember but i remember being
moved they did something really
interesting
uh
to get
me on the edge of my emotions david
nutter director andrew kreisberg jeff
johns greg berlanti we went in to do
that scene
in the prison and david came up to me
and said we've written some lines
that we didn't want you to see or hear
until for granted
until this moment
and it's my shot
so don't come in on your cue
don't kill come in
until he says the words whatever it was
i love you dad
and i'm sitting there we'll see now i'm
really listening you know meisner would
have been so pleased i was
riveted you know
what's he going to say
and he gets to the part where he says
you remember when you told me to change
my name because you didn't want anyone
to associate me with you well i'm glad i
didn't change my name i am proud of you
and i am proud to be your son
i lost it
so much so
that it was
unusable but
we said do it again right away don't cut
tape just do it again
and i was able to manage
the emotion and it was still there
people said how did you work up the
emotion for those father-son scenes i
said the problem wasn't working up the
emotion the problem was not letting the
emotion run away with you so that you're
up there having a wonderful masturbatory
experience and the audience is going god
there should be room for me
true true because i think you know
somebody told me once if you're doing a
scene where you have to you know cry you
should think of not crying because most
people don't want to cry and they end up
crying so you're really trying not to
cry and that
is what really affects people i think i
think that sort of reaction what were
the lines yeah go ahead it's like
playing drunk
yeah you know people who are drunk are
trying not to look drunk yeah
yeah that's true
mostly most often unless you're really
obnoxious you know